dans la 12e circonscription des yvelines
c'est la candidate françoise pinson qui
représente le parti communiste français
un mouvement qu'elle a rejoint il ya
plus de vingt ans elle était suppliant
que dans la sixième circonscription des
yvelines pour les législatives de 2012
cette fois elle se présente comme
candidate dans la 12e et développe ses
axes de campagne au micro de camille
lambert c'est surtout contre la loi
travail et contre les ordonnances là
c'est une sachs aussi parce que plus on
aura de députés au niveau 2
de ses instances et de l'assemblée plus
on pourrait faire reculer le ces lois
qui sont complètement à l' inverse de ce
que pour laquelle on se bat et je suis
pas du tout une professionnelle de la
politique et mon but il
il est pas de faire sa bombe utile et
des proches des gens et d'apporter les
valeurs que le parti il a par rapport à
aux gens par rapport aux piquets et
pisciacaise